hey youtubers is charlie so for today's
bonus video i wanted to talk a little
bit about what's going on with davos
over the wall his arc as well as some
changes i think they're making with
brands are from book stuff so just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far i did
pull some questions answer because i
haven't done a QA a little while so
after i talk about Davos brand stuff
i'll do a QA Davos stuff first just
because liam Cunningham has been doing a
bunch awesome stuff lately especially
dropping entire scenes from the first
episode so when asked to describe the
season he just talked about this intense
amount of carnage that was going to be
happening along with some business as
usual and being really excited for what
he called a lot of newness in what I
think that means is that we're just
gonna be seeing a lot more Davos at the
beginning of the season because right
now Jon Snow is still dead the Nights
Watch are coming after them so he's
gonna have to form some sort of unholy
alliance with his mortal enemy
Melisandre and when he said there'll be
some business as usual I think he's
talking about the drama up at the wall
as well as his relationship with
Melisandre even though they're working
together they're still going to hate
each other a little bit so you really
like that energy between the two of them
there's going to be plenty of that for
the first couple of episodes when the
Jon Snow popsicle thaws out and starts
to walk again that's when I think we'll
see some of that carnage the carnage
that he's talking about is obviously
stuff that's happening in the north
because Dana Dave got super hardcore
with security this year so the pages
that actors received were really only
localized to the scenes that they were
in so when Davos talks carnage he's
probably talking about like this scene
here along with the stuff with the
Bolton's is happening later in the
season as much as the show changes the
book storyline I feel like that's
actually a really good thing in Davos
this case because liam Cunningham such
an amazing actor so I'm wondering what
his relationship is going to be with the
new Johnstone because he's gonna have to
take charge for this first couple of
episodes until really gets going
but I still feel like there's gonna be
this big Davos Melisande return around
especially with Melisandre when she
finds out what's going on with Jon Snow
like she has this big crisis of faith in
the first episode that's clearly gonna
be her arc where she hits rock bottom
some crazy WTF happens and it completely
reignites her faith davos will also
probably have a version of that he's not
really a believer in the red God the way
Melisandre is he's not quite as
religious but remember the quote that
Jorah gave to Tyrion about Daenerys
birthing those dragons Tyrion is a
skeptic so as they're traveling together
surgery explains how he became a
believer when he saw her walk out of the
fire unburnt with those baby dragons so
I feel like the same thing is going to
happen with Sir Davos he'll be like the
surge aura of Jon Snow's storyline minus
the sexual tension but moving under
brand stuff this is going to be really
fun if you're a big fan of magic on the
show bran is going to be the biggest
conduit for that outright magic now
there's magic as part of Melisandre
storyline there are magical situations
and then there are other situations when
people consciously practice magic and
that's going to be brand in season 6 so
that makes me think that they're going
to use him as a conduit to explain all
the magical things on the show like as
the three-eyed Raven is explaining his
abilities to him through the season
whatever form that Jedi training is
going to take that is going to be when
we're going to get the most literal
explanation of how magic works on the
show like even though in the books there
are a bunch of the people that know a
lot about magic like Marwan the mage
really interesting character from the
books he's the archmaester that you
would go to learn about the dark arts
from anything magical really at the
Citadel TV show definitely not going to
do him in the books he said it to marine
with the idea of becoming de nurses
Meister so in the books were actually
probably gonna learn a lot about magic
through his character but because the TV
show isn't doing him you don't get any
that explanation so they kind of have to
give that to another character which is
why I think they're going to do that
with bran the way the actor that plays
brand described brand in season six is
that he the producers played it as if
bran had been watching the TV show the
whole time so he has an idea for what's
going on all over the world so everyone
in the story is concerned with our own
Varys is a good example of a
character that is trying to play a
larger game Fran will be one of the few
to know what's really going on more of
Ice and Fire things that are going on
let's do some questions so slight Cohen
asks could you please do a video about
Sam Charlie I feel like they didn't add
him to the trailer because newsa John's
death may change his story line in
potential news of John's resurrection
too well I've actually done Samwell
Tarly videos really he's going to the
Citadel to learn to become a maester
we're gonna see a lot of his family so
he'll be down in the reach it is my
great hope that we will also see a lot
of high guard in this season because
there's a lot of tyrelle stuff that's
happening in King's Landing now Sam
wells family does not live at Highgarden
they live at horn Hill which is nearby
but it's not near old town and it's not
near Highgarden so in the way during
season 5 Tyrion traveled all around like
we
volantis through tyrion then we went to
marine we'll probably see a couple
different places through samwell's
character but because there's so much
going on with these other really big
characters like the stuff in the north
the stuff in King's Landing it remains
to be seen how much Sam well we'll be in
the season Tony casma asks being Queen
regent and queen with Cersei and
Marjorie be required to use Kingsguard
in their trials I assume you're talking
about the trial of the faith no they
could probably pick anybody they wanted
to fight for them even if you haven't
read the books you've probably done the
math from the trailer Robert strong is
going to be Circe's proxy in any fight
that she's going to start and she
definitely looks like she's going to be
starting some fights next question
prongs ass jon is in ghosts potty he
lives as ghosts Melisandre with her
voodoo using ghosts will bring back John
that seem that you seem very certain of
that I would just be prepared for a
slightly different interpretation I
think if John were actually in ghosts
body when the Nights Watch starts to
break down the door in this clip those
would be acting less like a wolf in more
like jon snow like oh here we go like he
be a little less feral and i think in
this scene here we're probably going to
see him take down at least one or two of
the Nights Watch in a really wolf like
manner the george r martin has explained
that all the star children had the
ability to warg some of them just aren't
conscious of it yet I think they'll
focus less on that with Jon Snow
storyline in more with arias starline
like her awakening to her ability to see
through animals eyes Allah cat of the
canals next question Yusuf asks what
about Loras Tyrell we haven't seen him
for a long time well if Marjorie is
still being held by the faith and so is
laura's probably in because the actor
was cast on another show he was cast as
the new Iron Fist for Marvel I'm
wondering if he's going to get killed
off this season just because the actors
doing the Iron Fist stuff doesn't
guarantee that he's going to die on Game
of Thrones because they only do 10
episodes of Game of Thrones they're only
going to do 13 episodes iron fist so
they can totally schedule those around
each other but I don't really know what
the exact filming schedule is for Iron
Fist so don't be surprised if Flores
gets squished by the faith during season
6 that would actually be a pretty big
WTF that would incite the Tyrells to war
thank you so much everyone for asking
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do because they're doing the red
carpet premiere for season six tonight
there might be some cool stuff happening
if there is I'll totally do a video for
it next week giveaway time though
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Ben Bennett you had a
twenty-dollar amazon gift
art be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so i can get your
contact details that's just on the about
page if there's any bonus videos that
you guys want a request just let me know
in the comments below if you guys
haven't seen it yet you can click here
for that big davao scene from episode 1
and you can click here for my Tower of
joy teaser video so excited for tower of
joy thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you